on the ground in south korea a mixed
response to u.s president joe biden's
visit
these demonstrators welcomed him seeing
this as an opportunity to present a
united front against north korea
that follows reports leader kim jong-un
may be about to conduct a seventh
nuclear weapons test
but here activists concerned about an
arms race are calling for peace
when the two presidents met at a summit
on saturday security was high on the
agenda today president and i
committed to strengthening our close
engagement and work together to take on
challenges of regional security
including addressing the threat posed by
the democratic people's republic of
korea by further strengthening our
deterrence foster to working toward
complete denuclearization of the
principle
they discussed enhancing sanctions and
expanding the scope of combined military
exercises
biden also said he's not opposed to
meeting kim jong-un if he's sincere
both president yun and president biden
also said they were ready to help north
korea deal with an outbreak of covet 19.
we live in an era where the economy is
security and security is the economy
disruption in the supply chain caused by
changes in the international security
order is directly related to the lives
of our people
but analysts say that may not be enough
to bring north korea to the negotiating
table kim jong-un regime appears to be
determined to develop
the military
capability
to make sure that north korea will be
armed to have a sufficient capability to
hold u.s forces and civilian populations
in south korea and in japan as hostage
although countering china's dominance in
the region was not explicitly mentioned
the biden administration has made no
secret of the fact it views china as a
strategic challenge
in tokyo on monday president biden will
unveil the indo-pacific economic
framework its members will include south
korea and japan analysts say the u.s is
reasserting itself in the region years
after former president donald trump
pulled out of the trans-pacific
partnership trade pact
however china sees that agreement as an
attempt to marginalize it a chinese
foreign ministry spokesman criticized
the u.s on friday saying it should do
more to contribute to peace in the
region instead of creating divisions
florence louis al jazeera seoul